so thank you very much thank you very
much for the introduction and also thank
you very much for the organizers for
inviting me and also for inviting me to
this workshop so my talk is is related
to this ongoing workshop which dick
mentioned but they talk and I'm very
impressed at all the world experts which
the Institute managed to attract for
these workshops but this talk isn't or
endorsed experts it's a more general
talk and it's not a survey talk either
it's kind of a journey through various
topics in which I've been by which I've
been intrigued in this area so so so let
me start so i'll say some very general
things so the first thing is that the
computer science has gone a very long
way with just using kind of yes no
criteria so with during conception of
computer computation what has come out
of it is that not only is the model of
computation everything just yes no
enough but even considering the problems
to be yes no problems are very Universal
and kind of good enough for for
computation and so besides the fact that
we all carry around powerful Turing
machines in our pockets now other
important consequences I think of
obscuring tuacahn computing was the rise
of discrete mathematics that because
computation discrete computation is so
successful you know why look anywhere
else and this tradition of of yes no
computation is enormously successful of
course beyond cheering and certainly one
very major achievement was that of a PMP
come discover NP completeness in the
early 70s which was done in the
tradition of computing quantities with
mathematics which is very kind of yes no
and by quantities when I contrast
quantities with yes no I'm very modest
so if you got two or three values that's
a quantity for me I don't
need an infinite number yes I just want
to go yes no so the question is you know
in computer science do we have to go
beyond that and so maybe not I'm so the
argument for yes is first there are many
problems in the world which are
inherently quantitative so you know
maybe we should give them their due
respect but maybe the more important
reason in my mind is that so the main
quarrel I have with this tradition is
that is internally it's not totally self
fulfilled in particular the NP
completeness question isn't resolved so
from that point of view looking broader
somewhere else to get inspiration for
what it all means is a justification in
itself so and ok so the other general
comment about computer science from
people who've not computer scientists is
that of course many computer scientists
look at the computer in some sense here
we are looking at computer science
before we get to the computer we're
looking at the application think about
applications before you get to the
computer and of course the observation
is that the ink is incredible science
justify the applications before you
touch the computer okay so okay so I'll
define a few things which will be very
familiar familiar with two experts so
I'll look at applications which are to
do with graphs so this is a graph it's
got four vertices and some edges and
okay this graph happens to be at hazard
name is the complete graph on four
vertices it's called k4 and I look at a
particular question about graphs which
is matchings so given a graph with these
vertices and edges and matching is just
a set of edges from the graph which
don't share any vertex so this is a
matching the set of edges happens to the
one edge that's another matching two
edges but the point is the edges don't
meet anywhere so this is a matching and
a matching is perfect if these edges in
fact
go to every vertex so this to edge
matching is a perfect matching ok so the
various questions you can ask one is the
existence question like p.m. perfect
matchings does she have a perfect
matching existence question and for this
example the answer is yes it's got the
perfect matching I've shown you one
another question is counting how many
perfect matchings does it have and the
answer is three because you could you
can take this one you could take you to
vertical edges or you could take the two
diagonal edges the all three perfectly
good perfect matchings but another thing
which is tradition for combinatorial
lists is to make a polynomial out of it
which means that you add a variable for
every edge or first you name the
vertices numbers 1 2 3 4 and so the edge
x 2 3 goes from vertex to vertex 3 and
then the polynomial you associate with
with a spear five matching problem has a
one monomial for each perfect matching
and the monomial x 1 to x 34 are the
labels of the of that big the perfect
matching ok so this is a generating
polynomial for perfect matchings so in
general friendly combinatorial problem
you can ask you know is there solution
how many solutions and you can also make
up this this polynomial which somehow
you know has one if you plug in one for
the variables you get the three so in
some sense these problems get harder and
harder but in other sense they become
more algebraic more mathematical so it
helps to go in that direction sometimes
ok so
so if a special case if the graph is
bipartite which means that you can split
the edge the vertices into two sets and
all their just go from one set to the
other they'll go from left to right then
there's another little population which
is that you can keep the same numbers to
the vertices on the right as the left
and then the variables get renamed but
still this is still the perfect matching
polynomial but then you can regard these
entries as entries of a matrix and then
this function is also known as the
permanent so it's a polynomial where you
look at all the entries you multiply
sets of entries all in different rows
and columns in all possible ways ok so
it's likely determinant except there's
no Sun no signs ok so there are many
interesting polynomials you can
construct on on such a graph so the
determinant is equivalent to lin algebra
the permanent have discussed and then
there any number of other things you can
you can do so for example if you get a
network you can regard each variable as
the probability of that edge failing and
then you may want to compute some
question about the reliability of this
network maybe probably that it
disconnects so that some nerd gets
isolated or anything else or reliability
problems and all these things are just
polynomials in these variables and then
you can just pick a polynomial a problem
which you know is hard like Hamilton
circuits and you could make up the
Hamilton during a circus polynomial ok
so so well so it turns out that when you
ask how hard these are to compute then
as winner the determinant is easy linear
algebra is equivalent to it but it turns
out that all the other ones I've
mentioned and almost anything else you
care to think of return out to be hard
and so the best way known is by some
exponential computation and
so we'll say a few more a little bit
more about what's involved but sorry so
some sense it's our Drake framework is
where people may have come across
computational complexity even before the
computer scientists I did it was called
the curse of dimensionality the idea
that they're familiar operations you do
I which are easy but if you do it in
many dimensions the you pay exponential
costs so just one illustration so the
permanent which I defined is a sum of
products and so this is a matrix of
terms and use summer of all permutations
and then take a product of elements one
from each row and one from each column
okay and since they're in fact or
permutations this expression if you read
it out fully is exponentially long and
if you computer that that's not not
practical so an example of a polynomial
which is easy to compute is again let's
look at the XR j as a as a matrix so
let's ignore the wise so xij is matrix
so here's some agree with Jay means you
some each row okay so you've got a
matrix you sum up all the interest in a
row you multiply these together fruitful
for each of the rows so this is a very
easy expression of size n squared so
this is easy to compute and just a
little variation so in your matrix every
element in the wife in the jth column
are multiplied by a new variable Y J
okay it still easy easy to compute but
so this is an easy compute the thing up
there looks hard and contact you to be
hard but by the curse of dimensionality
people mean that even though this is
something very tan easy to compute this
polynomial certain operations which you
think ought to be easily like
differentiation or integration become
hard in high dimensions
and in fact why one reason to understand
how these are hard is that if you just
differentiate this easy expression you
get the permanent and if you integrate
it you also get a permanent and you're
integrating n fold or over these various
new variables okay you can easily easily
check that so you know so the calculus
we were talking high school we thought
about everything was computationally
easy differentiate 3x squared we knew
have to do it but in high dimensions it
becomes equivalent to this permanent
okay um so how do i just want understand
the difficulty of these various
polynomials well in computer science a
very important technique is just
reduction is no you don't understand
problem your problem be but you try to
show that if you could do problem be the
blue thing then you could easily do
problem a you can transfer the
difficulty of problem of problem a to
problem B and their various notions of
reduction and a very important one is
it's called a co-production where to do
the green problem take some input you do
some computation on the input and then
you just apply the you apply the result
of the computation to the input of your
blue problem and lo and behold the
answer to the blue problem is the answer
to the original green problem okay so
this is a simple reduction you could
imagine use the blue triangle many
different times but you just use it once
the answers are the same but you have to
do some pre-computation so so it turns
out that many NP complete problems are
complete we used two are equivalent in
this sense so the question is are there
any simpler reductions and so the answer
is yes and so one is called projection
reduction and the difference is that
here there's no computation competitions
going away all you do is you get some
inputs to the product to the problem and
you supply the same inputs to
as input to your to a blue problem but
maybe you know a pic input you you
supply three times and you also supply
some constants maybe okay so here
there's ray tube a little competition
and also almost in this reduction
computer computation has gone away it's
like a mathematical production it's a
substitution okay so the computer
science aspect seem to have simply
vanished and so in conventional terms
this is like before we did some
computation here but now we're using
this blue thing as a package okay we're
just plugging in values so is this an
important distinction oh well I know I
think maybe it is because if you think
about it so if you read during Spade in
1936 and had a lot of foresight what
would you have forecast well maybe two
things one is that everyone would carry
around a powerful chori machine in their
pockets in 80's time you would be
incorrect the other thing you may have
forecast is that if this Universal
computation is so magical maybe every 18
years later would be programming all day
and that that's not true most of us
don't program too much okay we just we
just plug in values to programs we use
programs as packages so no typing in an
email address in an email package
probably doesn't sound like something
too deep if not phenomenal to ponder
over but since I'm to become computing
also people don't program very much they
use packages for linear algebra so too
so the idea is that important problems
you want to solve you can solve by
plugging in values to some more generic
function okay and so so it turns out
that in fact all these polynomials and
any number of others you can think of
are are in fact equivalent to each other
just by this substitution without any
programming so the
so the sense in which the equivalent has
no computational content is just pure
pure mathematical content and also if
you ask that maybe in the definition of
the cross its completing like NP well
even there you can define the class in
which these things are competing almost
purely mathematically as no competition
in there so one could argue that clearly
this phenomenon of np-completeness are
in other classes what's clearly
discovered by computer scientists but
it's a much more general kind of
mathematical phenomenon and so you know
it's so not obvious why Archimedes
couldn't have conceptualized it there's
no no we just plug in values okay so
it's a substitution the most basic
mathematical notion so so then the
question of whether whether the
permanent although the permanent is
equivalent by the substitution to almost
everything every polynomial you can
think of in this this form formulation
is is in fact how does have an easy
computation can also reformulate as
whether it's a it's a projection of
something easy to compute the
determinant so this is a mathematical
problem which is being widely pursued
again it's got no superficially
mathematical content it's a question of
whether this point this matrix function
you can get from this one by by
substitution so okay so okay so this
tall guys have a plan okay so I've done
the first segment which is emphasizing
that they're counting and algebraic
complexity are very much related okay so
um so I want to get to my second part
which is holographic algorithms and and
I'll start the same way so what I said
was that many important problems you can
reuse to each other just by substitution
so then the question is is this the
simplest relationship between two
problems you can have or is
something even simpler which which helps
okay so so it's hard to imagine that
there's anything simpler but there is
and the simpler thing is to do nothing
okay you do nothing and what this means
is that if you want to solve this
problem you you got some inputs for
inputs you just possibly input to
yourself to other problem and you get
the answer okay doesn't look impressive
but so this really means that these two
functions are literally the same
function the same function okay so so
this is called a whole graphic reduction
okay it's extremely simple okay and so
we're basically are asking when are two
functions the same okay so maybe there's
a theorem that Apple's our oranges but
you've just missed this piece of
information okay so since that kind of
thing when there are two things which
looks at this similar but in fact all
the same so that's what you want to use
it for and so to illustrate this again
let's go back to matchings and so we
need a bit of notation to introduce
these are called signatures so so now
I'll code up the instead of using words
to describe a comet or property I'll use
some notation and what this says is that
so I'll look at properties which takes
up set of edges and so this represents
version 0 1 2 or 3 and the one here
means that whenever there is one edge
chosen instant to a node I like that I
give it away one and if there were zero
edges out if it was zero two or three
edges I'd give it zero okay so for
example okay so this little notation
okay so the number of matchings in this
graph is three as before another
properties parity is this number or door
even it's odd and you can also ask your
existence questions so this notation
doesn't buy us what the question you're
going to ask okay so just to emphasize
the notation so so again so this is a
subset of edges somebody's use have have
will have one edge you some have to and
this property would say that whenever
I've got one edge used i'll give it a
rate of three whenever I've got two
edges used give it away 2-2 okay so this
particular example for this property
would this value will be three times
three x minus two x minus 2 which is 36
okay and then the counting problem is to
add is for all subsets of these edges to
count up its value ok that's a counting
problem so I've defined a signature
which defines the problem and the
exponential many different subset of
edges in a graph that's why these
problems are hard potentially and I want
to compute the sum of all exponentially
many things of this value ok so in this
case since its value is 1 i'll just be
counting perfect matchings because the
only etc which wouldn't become 0 are
those where every vertex is met with one
edge ok so this counts perfect matchings
ok but as an illustration now I'll use
this function not too rich unless you're
an expert in this area you will never
have heard of I'm sure for good reason
and so this says that you know if
there's one edge in turn into vertex I
like it there's three I like it as well
if there was zero that's ok as well but
if there's a single vertex with with two
edges incident then
the whole thing would be with nothing
okay okay so what I want to count is is
how many subsets of edges are they in a
graph where no subset causes exactly two
of them to meet at a vertex okay so
strange combinatorial problem and so why
not this okay um and okay so it's an
exercise so question is is this easy or
hard okay so is this the exponential
effort you have to enumerate all the
cases or is there some some shortcut so
this is what we study in complexity
theory these kind of questions and so
this particular problem was open for
folk for a while for some strange thing
and never knew what it was okay so for
as an exercise for this for vertex graph
for this complete graph the answer is 15
you know you can choose no edges you can
chew if you choose one edge you can do
it in in six ways they're all good
solutions and 3023 ages 6 edges there's
no way of choosing five edges because
then somewhere you've got to it is
coming to a vertex circuits aren't is 15
ok so the exercise for those from seen
this is is this an easy problem or hard
problem okay it looks like some
arbitrary come into our problem and so
this is you can ask this question for
any any graph where every vertex has
degree 3 and so you know so off the
internet you can get lots of them these
are nice and symmetric that's certainly
different and you know most numbers of
these ok so again so each of the each of
these has 16 vertices 24 edges so
they're two to the 24 different sets of
edges you can consider each has a value
and we want to add up the values / 01
want to add up how many you get
okay so it's a strange problem so okay
so the question is your heart well so
there is a theorem which says that of
this apple and oranges kind and the
theorem says that this is a problem
we're discussing how many solutions when
not to okay and so the theorem says that
this problem is ich it's the same
problem with something else ok the again
what I'm saying there are two functions
which are the same function no
substitutes and nothing the same
function except the apple and orange
which are really the same but but you
never knew and then this is the other
function and then you have to figure out
what this means ok so this function says
that you get three edges coming in that
you get a value sorry then you get a
value why if there's no edges coming you
get a value X and if there's one or two
you get value zero ok and in fact the x
and y are some funny quantities with
root 5 then ok but then our question is
so if this you can't recognize what this
meant so can anyone who hasn't seen this
before recognize what what this means so
this is a much more intuitive function
offers so what are we kind of counting
here so what are what are solutions to
this so what edge sets are solutions to
this which I have nonzero weight
yes yes so the point is that at Lisa
pose the graph is connected the point is
that if you go to vertex you get some
credit for it if there are no edges it
is into it you're the value X and as you
go out they know if there's no edge here
then the combini edge there or there
because otherwise this will get a value
0 okay so once you start with a whiz
with no edges adjacent to vertex then
this spreads like a contagion the only
way to get non zero weight is to cover
the whole graph with zero or you can
start the vertex give it weight why all
the three edges are there then my
contagion the whole graph has to be full
of edges and all have wait why okay so
the moral is that the number of the
answer to this is always x to the n plus
y to the n where ok so the conclusion of
the theorem is that for this graph it's
got a no 10 vertices so either it's
actually its x2 10 they're just two
solutions which are non zero X the back
weights are x2 10 y to the 10 and x and
y are these funny things with Ruth
rhymes in and if you work this out
amazingly you're the whole number 625
and in fact that's the number of
solutions of this graph ok let the
number of this strange not to solutions
of this graph ok but what's the
important point of course the important
point is that this answer didn't depend
on the graph ok this is true for every
graph with n vertices
okay so this graph okay so this function
so what do we conclude about this
function how many not two solutions for
these okay these have 16 vertices guess
number of solutions but both graphs have
the same number of solutions you know
the answer without looking at the input
so okay so it's probably not a very
interesting problem okay so the reason
why is no one's ever heard of this
problem is that you know no no one would
want to compute this okay but anyway but
but so this is kind of a parlor trick
okay but it illustrates the power of
mappings which of having two ways of
saying what the same function is so
briefly what the theorem does the
theorem is really something proved by a
computer in in a micro second so what's
behind the proof is are just some linear
identities so these are the two
commercial things you're showing to be
equal and so basically you you stretch
out these these this is a three input 0
3 input functions so you have to stretch
it out into a 22 this root 3 so you know
so this is really the same as 1101
stretched out okay so all the places
where the address has a single one this
this and this has a 1 so this one
becomes three ones and this one becomes
11 okay and this thing gets stretched
out to this so so the fact that these
problems are the same is equivalent to a
statement that there's a linear
transformation between these signatures
okay so by having formalized the
committal problem as a as a signature
the reward is you don't have to think
anymore you plug it in the inter
computer and the computer will tell you
what are equivalent problems
okay so I haven't done all the details
but it's basically you're looking for a
simple linear transformation and happens
to be these quantities with root fives
in which map between these two problems
okay so that's a example of a two ways
of looking at the same function okay so
okay so for every graph this path this
function is the same as this function
they're the same give every input
they've got the same answer but it
doesn't look at that look at it that way
from just looking at the definition so
that's what the whole graphic
transformation is so this particular
instance is an instance of what's called
a Fibonacci gate this was studied
systematically about shailu and sha so
it's a general class with properties
vaguely related to what I described it
can be studied systematically and and
roughly it's the cost is defined by
having a single recurrence relation
which which defines all the signatures
which what you have okay so um it's kind
of a two second explanation of what
these holographic reductions are very
informal this is how i like to think
about it is that you've got your you got
this graph which you're asking some
question about so we make it kind of
bipartite we call them generators and
recognizes and will shoot out some
particles from the generators so
generator shoot at end NP NP that the
ends in peas and the recognizes receive
them and so the generators will generate
the eight different combinations of ends
and peas with different coefficients
these are numbers and the recognizes
will receive three of these or some
other number of these with different
numerical values and then the this the
value of this whole thing shkola holland
is the sum over the values of all states
so state is just an assignment of peace
and install the edge
if you signed piece names to all the
edges then these generators and
recognizes will give you numbers
everywhere you multiply them together
that's the value of the state you add up
all the exponential number of states
okay so that's at a generic kind of
exponential some expression bit like
partition functions in physics and so
also what okay so if you want to express
perfect matchings and you make sure that
you'll that every node emits just a
single p and every node receives just a
single p okay and if anything else you
zero at ok so this somehow counts
perfect matchings now this may be easy
to computer how to compute this is just
the definition so far but in the same
spirit we can add to the definition and
what the whole graphic transformation is
is that use you have an eavesdropper on
each line and this isn't a malicious
each droplet this is kind of a neutral
one and this is really a translator and
what the translator dodges it translated
just receives a signal translate it into
his or her own language by this linear
transformation and then turns its assets
back again into the original language ok
just like you know having these blue
people these original people communicate
in English and these eavesdroppers so
translate or they get into French and
they translate back in English and pass
it on ok so they're totally innocuous
they don't interfere with what's going
on but they do have a different view of
what's going on ok these people think of
it what's going on in French and these
people think of it in English ok so in
our terms there's a linear
transformation so this is internal
linear transformation on the definition
of the function and so there's many ways
of looking at the same function being
computer
that's kind of a intuitive definition
and so how this is used so in fact you
know saying look you know there is
amazing different functions and how come
you didn't know that they're very the
same so those things are hard to find
but even without that these things have
uses because usually to find the first
algorithm we transform some natural
signature to an unnatural one but one
for which we know how to compute fast
okay and so one thing to reduce to is
this famous result of pitcher gasoline
and temporally that you can compute the
number of perfect matching to in planar
graphs efficiently so horror graphic
transformation just the reduction and if
you want to use it you have to when you
reduce a to be you have to know
something about a or b so you can use it
both ways so if B you can you compute
efficiently then you can compute a as
well and also you can use the other way
as evidence of hardness so if one
problem you know is say complete so
sharp become PP means that it's is
provably a hardest counting problem in
its cars then by this reduction we can
show maybe that your problem is as hard
the same problem okay but as
practitioners know so by itself this
method doesn't do that much but in
combination with other techniques which
are well known it is a very useful
technique and the other techniques for
reducing problems to each other so one
is to have gadgets so this goes back to
NP completeness firstly the cops paper
and for counting problems polynomial
interpolation where you reduce one
problem to another by having by crawling
many calling the other problem many
times and be using the issue to one of
interpolation interpolation okay so
maybe this sounds strange so what's this
you know do nothing reduction so you
know are there any classical examples
where they're two functions which are
the same but people people have noticed
or took a long time noticing of course
you could say that you know almost any
stationary mathematics is of this nature
you sure i equals B and presumably
people didn't didn't know it before so
some sense that's always saying but this
is a bit different because we're trying
to show that the two functions even
graph functions which which are really
the same but it's not obvious that is
the same and this sort of saw one
classical example I know is a very
important wise by Van de verdun so this
is important in in cisco physics easing
problem so this is the easing problem
also known as cuts in computer science
where you use these two signatures and
basically a here you go to vertex and
this may be either magnetic or not
magnetic and then these link vertices
and if you link to magnetic or two
non-magnetic 30 seats you get a certain
reward but if you link magnetic and
non-magnetic one then you get a
different room reward so this is the
easing problem and so van der Weyden has
a theorem which says that lo and behold
this is the same as some something else
which looks different and this is some
sort of parity problem this is looking
at sets of edges in a graph where
there's an even number of edges incident
to each each vertex okay so okay so he
had
okay so colon means that so I'm allowed
to use both both both signatures are
components ok so the colon means that
I'm going to use in a bipartite way so
these things will feed into these things
and these into these things okay
otherwise you could just put them put
put them together arbitrarily okay so
simpler usually interpretation is that
he's a vertices and then these are edges
which link two vertices ok and then
vandoren did had this funny need funny
weights ok so so first only for any
fixed arity you can formulate this as a
holographic reduction his proof didn't
look that way but again this is maybe a
very natural instance of holographic
reduction which your computer can prove
in in a mark micro second
well it means and you can use both of
these these signatures but but these
signatures have to be used opposite each
other so so the so the graph so I've got
a graph with edges and I sign the
signature to each vertex and you can
assign these to some visiting these to
some vertices the coulomb means that the
grout is bipartite and I have to sign
these on the left and these on the right
okay okay but this is equivalent to the
classical theory of the easing problem
for planar graphs okay I'm just pointing
out that some prehistory there okay so
okay so let's go on to ok so these these
segments get shorter and shorter so so
what do we like to prove in in income in
complexity theory well again these are
we discussing problems this is
application space and so NP is this
class of problems we can verify a
solution fast but you can this a
verified candidate solution fast but you
can't necessarily find one fast okay so
some things p is what you can compute
efficiently NP compds was probably the
hardest members of NP so it's possible
that all three classes are the same
because as an epson as the major open
problem and but but if it's but if it's
not then one of the result which is
known called agnes theorem is that if p
is different from NP then they're also
problems in NP which are different from
either of these so there are problems of
intermediate difficulty so NP i then p
collapses to pee or it's really
complicated and complicated means that
there are other strange things which are
neither p nor NP complete
okay well so sure well certainly
resolving P equals NP would be a good
thing to do but what's the second-best
so the second-best rich people can do is
what's called a dichotomy theorem and
this is defining some class here of
problems which is hopefully a natural
class which has the property that a win
in this class isn't syntactically easily
recognized class everything is either MP
compete or MP there's there's no no
latinus theorem okay and so kind of the
practical utility of this is I suppose
computer scientists put other people out
of work so this is an attempt to put
computer scientists out of work because
suppose the utility of a complexity
theory is that if you have an arbitrary
problem you can take it to your computer
scientist friend and say is this easy or
is it hard but we're trying to also
automate this so if your problem lies
within an easy recognized class you just
look it up you just work it out for
yourself is it easy or hard okay so
there is a long history of dichotomy
theorems and and for counting I think
these are especially impressive and so
some very impressive ones I've been
proved by people who are in this room so
I Lu Chen and some others and they
really show that for some very very well
defined class you can figure out what
easier has so I'll give you an example
which may not be the best illustration
but it's easy to explain in the
remaining minutes okay so a third issue
you can worry about this parity so is
the number of solutions even or odd so
this is somehow intermediate between
counting and existence it's got some
advantages okay so and again for parity
their problems which are compete for
parity is can't mod 2 and problems which
are easy okay so for these i'll give you
one
theorem which again I'm saying because
there many others I could mention by
this one is kind of easy to explain at
this point okay so what is it about so
again we see these these signatures so
can we recognize any of the any of these
so okay so okay so this is like perfect
matchings so we insist one neighbor
being a one you know but not of the
others and so this thing sounds a bit
like this not to this is like not to it
it starts like not 201 ok not to ok so
anyway so what these theorems say is
that ok so now another commerce between
these signatures ok so so you give me
any set of signatures you can make up of
zeros and ones and my question is you
know if I throw these on to know to a
graph I want to compute how my solutions
that problem has the parity of it is an
easier heart and so this theorem says
that yes in every case it's either
polynomial time or it's complete ok so
just two problems ok but you know you
can come out with signatures of any
sizes and will tell you whether the
problem is is your heart so for most of
these things most problems are hard ok
but there are some easy cases and in
this case the easy cases are you can
recognize so these are kind of so here
you insist the neighbors are even or odd
so this is like solving equations mod 2
so these are linear equations not to so
the variables ok so I've got my comments
wrong here but so the variables either 0
1 and then the equations insist on
whether they say like an even number of
these variables after the true
because so these are linear equations
these are matchings which I've discussed
so the Perry family but there although
even number of perfect matchings that we
can do a polynomial time that these
people now she gates like the not to
which is another category then there's a
fourth class called vanishing sets which
are really sets of sets which are really
degenerate in that given any compare any
of these components in any arrangement
they aren't is always 0 but the other
theorem says is that you know if the set
of components you give me is within one
of these lines then it's polynomial time
computable if it's not I'll give is a
mixture of these lines or something
outside these lines then it's tempe hard
ok so this is a kata me every problem is
categorized ok so a secondary question
is whether the dichotomy is is
computable but in this case is is open
so we're saying that every subsidies are
the easy or hard whether the consultant
can tell you which is which is not
totally resolved ok so so I think one of
the achievements of of this of people
working accounting theory all these very
strong dichotomy theorems which which
for quite the impressive postural
problems really resolved that you know
either these problems others are just
one problem if the thing collapses or at
most to the easy ones on the hard ones
the hard ones are all the same easy 10
polynomial time ok so that's some notion
of programs okay so okay so lastly I've
just got one slide for this so so
clearly many people actually want to
compute these quantities and for many of
them you don't want to know the exact
answer approximate answers are enough
and if you're satisfied with approximate
answers there's some chance of getting
them even when the exact answer you
can't get
so one issue with this field is that
although I emphasize that these Reyes
problems are very related to each other
you can map them to analogy to each
other by for example by these
projections substitutions these
approximations are lost so this sort of
class so the counting problems we
approximated get much more confusing
much more difficult so you know so on
enormous focus now is to understand the
complexity of approximate approximate
accounting all these kind of problems
which is much more complicated than I've
made out so just okay so there's some
general notions that under some
conditions approximate counting is the
same as some other things and won't be
other things is random generation so
randomly generating a solution is are
the same difficulty as counting the
approximate number that's often used so
just an example of a of a triumph so
resolve the germ synced in Bogota that
the permanent of matrices with positive
entries I can be approximated in
polynomial time so the hardness is hard
in the exact sense but not if you have
zero one for example but they'll also a
problem so for example so this is this
is counting matchings in bipartite
graphs if you want can't to current
matchings in arbitrary graphs look
similar that's totally open so
so in a box math counting we feel this
the lot lot has been done but there lots
of open problems so thank you
yes
well uh well you you are counting
something in the end so you do want to
enter the solution